27 year old out of ucla
james carpillion he's been solid so far
for the ace four and one
a 2.86 era only on one occasion has he
allowed more than three runs in a ball
game and that was back in seattle on the
31st of may in juniors face colorado
kansas city the yankees and the rangers
and the 2-2 pitch on the way swung
autumn as those that buy him a fastball
94 and that's the way our ball game
begins rangers first trip to the
coliseum
and this one out into left field that's
a base hit and so nate is aboard
it has the rangers first hit of the ball
game here's the one two pitch and swung
out at mesa high fastball elevator down
goes garcia two away
swinging gonna miss on a high fastball
so three strikeouts for copralian
and the rangers fail to score with the
a's coming up in the bottom half talk
about dominating for six innings gave up
just four hits to the athletics he did
leave with a lead
swung on him missed strike three gets
kemp to go after the high heat one away
and here's chapman with one out in the
first and no score and that's number 19.
right on cue a tremendous shot
deep in the bleachers and left by
chapman and it's one nothing is in the
bottom of the first
number 11 this year for the ace third
baseman
it's also a 16-game hitting streak
olson's having a huge month of june but
he strikes out swinging here two away so
there's been five outs recorded in the
game tonight and they're all strikeouts
and the pitch is swung on and grounded
weakly out to second solak just beyond
the rim has it tosses to first the sides
retired the a's get a run on the home
run by chapman and after one it's one to
nothing open
and he throws here's the 2-2 pitch and
that's taken ring him up perfect pitch
fastball
all the outs four outs for james all on
strikeouts and that'll bring up eli
white
now here's the one-two pitch swung onto
miss throws it by him again a fastball
down goes white five outs five
strikeouts
here's the wind-up and the two-two
delivery and that's why i'm gonna tap
her back toward the mount caprilian has
it flips over to first and james
cabrillo so far so good we go to the
bottom of the second it's one nothing
athletics you can't just automatically
put a certain series in the win column
or certain victories based on the
opposition and the record at the time
the change it bounced towards short
right there is elvis gloves it clean on
the first little low dug out by olsen
just in time
and quickly that's the second out here's
the 1-1 basketball driven in the gap in
right center loriano is on the run still
going reaches out and hauls it in
galloping out toward right center field
he makes the play and the rangers go one
two three
payoff pitch to kemp
and he pulls it over first down the line
fairball heading toward the corner and
gallows got to go get it tony's at
second base and he will gear down as
gallow with a good arm gets to the
baseball and brings it back in quickly
but kemp with his ninth double as he
stands at second base with two outs for
matt chapman
and the 1-0 pitch hit on the ground left
side charged by keiner falefa he uh
taps the glove once and then fires it
across in time to retire chapman for the
final out in the inning so no runs a hit
to god here in the top of the fourth and
that brings joey gallow to the plate
and this ball hit well
deep out to center field and that one is
gone
way up there
above the batter's eye and just to the
right of it
gala with a massive home run 17th of the
year and he has tied the game
and jen is a board with one out and then
here comes laureano
1-1 hit hard toward the gap and left
center closing on it as white he dives
and he lost it it's off him and it's on
the warning track racing to third base
is lowry they're going to send him home
here's the relay by connor for left not
in time it gets away from heim and all
the way to third base goes loriano
it's 2-1 oakland
a comedy of errors by the rangers and
oakland takes advantage
0-2
and a swing and a mess marlin strikes
out for a big second out of the inning
payoff pitch and a swing and a miss he
strikes out murphy
for a second time tonight that's five
strikeouts for fulton evans
pitch to eli that one is lying into
right that's a base hit they had the
overshift on three on the left side and
white hit a soft line drive to the
traditional second baseman spot rangers
are down by a run and they have a fast
mana board and the pitch there's a high
drive hit the center field moving back
loriano and he can't get it it's beyond
his reach it's off the wall white with
great speed being waved around third
he's digging for the plate and he will
score without a play it's an rbi double
for jonah heim and he has tied this game
at two caprileon trying to work out of
it at the belt here it is swung on a
five ball center field back as lauriano
nearing the track has room 10 feet from
the track and he makes the catch and
caprilian keeps the damage down the
rangers get one but they leave runners
at first and third the game tied at two
and here's joey who has struck you out
in homeward here's a swing and there's a
drive the opposite way to deep left kemp
is going back he looks and that ball is
history
joey gallo goes out bow clears the 14
foot high wall and gives the rangers a
three to two lead with his second home
run of the ball game now ready the turn
and here it is and then swung on a one
hopper right to seconds taken by lowry
and jed throws to first for the odd two
away and that'll bring up eli white
there's the wind up and the 1-1 on the
way and it's tapped to our third to his
left chapman giving way elvis fires
quickly and white who can really run is
not 6-3 and the inning is over but joey
gallo has been the big story tonight
only six hits for the rangers today four
for oakland and only one walk in the
game drawn by the a's and that pitch is
grounded over first that's a fair ball
down the line
and the counter follefa is on as uh seth
brown cuts to the foul line cuts it off
and the one two pitch on the way
curveball is a fly ball to left kemp
going back he's there fighting it he
makes the catch tony camp on a ball that
seemed to explode on him and maybe
looking up into the lights at the last
second made a good play and a well hit
ball the other way off the bat of brock
holt a four-pitch walk to open up the
bottom of the ink here's the pitch and
kemp swings and misses and lets it fly
swing and a miss high fastball got him
pegged down to first by heim is not in
time
here's the pitch to olson and the ground
ball hit right into the shift
it is brock holt over on the right side
fielding it tosses to first and the
sides retired a leadoff walk and nothing
more nick zolac one for three with a
single and the pitch
that's lifted in the air to deep right
field angling back is seth brown at the
wall he leaps and it's history just
barely beyond the reach of seth brown
nick solak ends a long home run drought
with an opposite field two run shot
and the rangers now lead it five to two
and kennedy comes in to try to get the
save 2.39 era
that one's a deep to right center field
and
that baby's gone
five to three
that one is driven down the line
and that baby's gone
and now it's a one-run game
five to four texas
it's got everybody on their feet now in
oakland and pender goes after the first
pitch pop up on the infield low waiting
on it
and he's got it
my
this one is over
and the rangers escape
with a 5-4 win in game one